it was too far from the front
nowhere near the parts of ukraine where
there was active fighting
in the west of the country ukrainians
say they felt safe
an illusion shattered on the morning of
march 13th by 30 russian missiles
less than three weeks into the invasion
of ukraine russia attacked the yavr of
military base
a training ground for new recruits and
volunteers the deepest attack into the
country and only 20 kilometers from the
polish border
dozens of people were injured and killed
every coffin
carrying the weight of a grieving family
as the weeks pass families across the
country
try to make sense of what happened
constantine was a weapons trainer at the
yavarev base
solomia widowed at 19 says all she can
do now is be strong for her son
he called me that morning and said not
to worry he said they were being fired
on but he was safe it was on another
base
he said that everything was fine
five minutes later when i called him
again after new explosions there was no
connection
she knew her husband was gone after
seeing his name on an instagram post
about casualties
grief stricken she was rushed to the
hospital
after the attack saw mia moved to
drohobich
to be closer to family
to share the load of loss
a soldier's wife and mother to be still
visibly numb
a soldier's mother unable to contain her
rage
do you russia really think will forgive
you that easily we won't forgive you
i'll stand for my son i'll take the
weapons and we'll be shooting into your
children if you don't stop your sons
your children fathers and husbands we
will all take up weapons and there'll be
no place for you in this world
we'll reach you and we will push your
way to siberia so that you'll be in the
cold soil without bread water food like
our children hungry frozen hiding in the
shelters without medication without
anything
constantine was raised by his stepfather
who says he will also be joining the
ukrainian military and deploying to the
same base where his stepson was killed
as the tally of the dead across the
country continues to go up absence
fills many houses in ukraine
where men continue to be called up to
lay down their lives
and women are left to carry their
memories
zayn basravi al-jazeera dr hobich